today we're going to talk about a
toolbox
no not this toolbox this one
a toolbox for brain research
looking at organs on chips organoids and
microscopy and why you should be excited
about them
and why should she care well the other
week now a whole series of articles came
out regarding potential fabrication of
data in many papers on outside
mississippi's resulting in millions of
dollars misspent and misdirecting
scientific advancements
alzheimer's is an age-associated
neurodegenerative disease that still
lacks an effective cure
and so it was not surprising to see
these articles cause quite a star
now i was going to make a video just on
that but this mini commentary only seems
to scratch the surface of all the
potential misconduct and data
fabrication
and also conflicts of interest with
companies and frankly i wasn't the best
person to discuss that
but even misconduct aside
with this enigmatic complex disease even
careful experiments done in good faith
can fail to replicate leading to dead
ends and unexpected setbacks
so as with alzheimer's disease we still
don't know how to treat many different
neurodegenerative diseases we don't
fully understand the cause
we don't know how personalized it is how
genetics affect things
we can't just take a biopsy of brains of
healthy people cell lines like
complexity and mouse models have been
scrutinized as not representing the full
process of disease manifestation
resulting in poor translatability to
human therapeutics
so in this video i thought i would put
my optimistic hat on and provide you
with an overview of the three novel
methods being employed that will help to
act as better models for brains to
advance neuroscience research
advance number one organ on a chip
these are miniature tissues grown inside
microfluidic chips about the size of a
usb stick
by coupling biology with microwave
technology you have these chips that
have little channels in them where
miniature tissues reside
the idea is that they better mimic human
physiology because they use human cells
and you can control the microenvironment
this is important because the ultimate
goal is to mimic aspects of human
pathophysiology and disease
and while these technologies have been
about for around a decade now it takes
time for the technology to mature you
have to validate it and optimize the
conditions
and so it's only been more recently that
we've seen it possible to do brain on
chips
these can be used for basic research or
for testing drugs and drug development
of neurodegenerative diseases
for example one company emulates bayou
is using their brain chip to research
mechanisms of neuroinflammation and
evaluate therapeutics
their brain chip has five cell types
including neuronal cells glial cells and
endothelial blood brain barrier cells
so this could also potentially be used
to understand how drugs can cross the
blood brain barrier
there are of course limitations and that
includes the fact that this approach is
quite technically complex and requires
specialized equipment
plus the small channels used in the
chips can cause shear stress on the
cells and the material that is commonly
used pdms apparently can absorb proteins
that can then leach later at
uncontrolled rates
that said i think this technology is
super cool and obviously goes way beyond
just neuroscience and with different
organs on chips can be applied in many
different research areas so i think i'll
definitely have to make a deeper dive
video sometime soon
so that brings us on to advanced number
two brain organoids
now brain organoids arguably sound
similar to brain on chips but they are
in fact very different
brain organoids are three-dimensional
human brain cultures
one way you can achieve this is by
taking some stem cells and directing
them to differentiate into different
brain tissues
and so you can therefore use them to
study human brain development and
function
there are a variety of ways you can go
about generating these organoids and
generally they can be split into two
self-explanatory subsets directed and
non-directed methods
the latter non-directed method referring
to how you keep things spontaneous
the idea that you just embed the cells
in suspension or in a matrix but
otherwise give the cells freedom to give
rise to cell diversity
and form complex cell cell interactions
obviously it wouldn't be wise for it to
be fully spontaneous because as an
experimentalist you want your model to
provide enough reproducibility
or to resemble something we would see in
our bodies so this is one of the
limitations how can we be certain we're
actually seeing physiological cell
interactions
but the reason i mentioned brain
organoids is due to some exciting
research coming out more recently
to go back to what i was saying at the
beginning of this video
neurodegenerative disorders have been
challenging to model in vitro owing to
their late onset
but a more recent study developed 3d
human neural cultures carrying
alzheimer's disease-related mutations
and showed that they recapitulated both
beta-amyloid and tau pathology
what the latest and greatest take this
one step further brain assembloids
controlled assembly or 3d brain cultures
here you make region-specific cognoids
and fuse them creating a modular system
enabling researchers to probe more
complex cell cell interactions and to
generate circuits from parts and ask
specific disease related questions
for example this 2020 paper generated a
functional human 3d cortical motor
assembly by connecting organoids
mimicking the brain cortex the spinal
cord and muscle
and in this model they could actually
see it function and so therefore this
model could be really important for
understanding diseases like parkinson's
or huntington's
so like with the brain on chips the
advantages of these organoids include
overcoming the issues with doing
experiments in a 2d dish format where
the cells are on a hard plastic surface
3d cultures rely instead upon
genetically encoded self-organization
principles to form structures that
resemble in vivo tissues
another perhaps surprising benefit is
that these brain organoids allow
long-term culture so we're talking here
months to years
so longer-term processes can be studied
such as maturation of the central
nervous system
but brain development is just one
application and the other of course
being disease modelling
so this brings us to advanced number
three expansion microscopy
which as hinted at by the name it
involves expansion
and so i think you're all familiar with
the concept of microscopy and so
expansion microscopy is where instead of
just zooming in with larger lenses and
magnifying the sample
you instead expand the sample whether
that be a tissue or cell and you do so
isotropically facilitating super
resolution imaging
this is achieved by introducing a
polymer network into a cellular or
tissue sample and physically expanding
the polymer using chemical reactions
the technique was formally introduced in
a 2015 article
pioneered by ed boyden and others at mit
in this article they show off some of
the uses of expansion microscopy
for example this figure you see now is
of fixed mouse brain tissue and compares
before and after the expansion technique
before being on the left and after on
the right
and you can see the resolution is much
greater following expansion
you can even distinguish the
architecture of the synapse the site of
electrical communication between two
neurons
the blue protein here showing bassoon a
presynaptic protein and in red a
postsynaptic protein homa1
further enhancements may be achieved
with expansion microscopy by altering
the properties of the polymer used for
the expansion so exciting times are
indeed ahead for neuroscience research
as ed boyden says it's becoming clear
that the expansion process will reveal
many new biological discoveries
if biologists and clinicians have been
studying a protein in the brain or
another biological specimen and they're
labeling it in the regular way they
might be missing entire categories of
phenomena
you can see this more clearly in a paper
that came out this year
where they used an iterative version of
expansion microscopy
to achieve expansion or feeling in this
paper they describe how you can see
amyloid nanoclusters in brain tissue
from a mouse model of alzheimer's
disease
this can be achieved because the
expansion causes molecular de-crowding
giving access for antibodies to bind
the expansion approach here shows these
periodic clusters of amyloid beta
while the pre-expansion staining only
detects large plaque centres
so all models are wrong but some are
useful
this famous quote by george box is a
timely reminder to not be pessimistic
but to remember that some models are
indeed useful as long as they provide
testable predictions
by knowing the advantages and
disadvantages of your model with
correctly controlled experimental design
all you can then do is follow the data
and use that to guide your next
experimental question
for these reasons it becomes hard to
predict the time scale for when we are
likely to see some of these new tools
and techniques translate into
therapeutics
but they for sure will reveal some new
understanding into the brain
and in fact we've only spoken about
three advances here and the fourth bonus
technology i chose not to mention are
brain machine interfaces because i made
a video on this previously
so with that i hope you've enjoyed this
video
thank you to my patreon supporters and
thank you for listening
you